the village of Bosch candy in the
foothills of the Tian Shan Mountains in
central Kyrgyzstan docked on Elima yacht
off is farmed and raised livestock all
his life it's the traditional existence
here but in recent years it's become
more difficult due to climate change is
the master we have less and less water
there's a river nearby and used to have
so much water you could barely cross it
on horseback but now the water barely
reaches the horse's belly attention it's
all semester student the mountains of
changshan are unique there are 50 500
species of plants here and many rare
animals such as the Marco Polo sheep
which are seldom seen nowadays the
glacier waters give them life but the
glaciers are receding the region's
biodiversity is in peril and life for
people here is getting more and more
difficult what can be done about it this
question led dothan al imam you drove to
a nearby village where Khanna John TF
lives with the help of environmental
organizations he's created a small oasis
here in the middle of the rocky desert
Khanna John taya grows apricots the only
fruit that can survive here this year's
harvest has already been sold it went to
Russia a good idea why waste your time
and energy on crops that won't ripen
here I could do it too sighs oh but to
come up with these ideas farmers have to
understand how to cope with changing
climate conditions help comes from
international organizations like the
German agency for international
cooperation or GI Z it trains farmers
with workshops and today a role-playing
game the farmers have to play various
parts including planners livestock
farmers and bookkeepers they're learning
how to deal with climate change instead
of watching helplessly
in a short time the farmers role play
their entire lives and suggest solutions
they're familiar with we analyzed the
most successful ones back in bosch candy
village the hope is that people here can
be better equipped for the future for a
life with climate change and not as
victims of it